[Music]
the general ground on which the movement
of these shapes produced from the notion
takes place is the consciousness
expressed in the first imaginative
language that of the epic where the
content devoid of a self is left
disunited
it is the commonality as such whose
wisdom finds utterance in the chorus of
the elders and the powerlessness of this
chorus the commonality has its
representative because the common people
themselves constitute merely the
positive and passive material of the
individuality of the government
confronting it
lacking the power of the negative it is
unable to hold together and to subdue
the riches and varied abundance of the
divine life but lets it all go its own
separate ways and in its reverential
hymns it extols each individual moment
as an independent god first one and then
another
but where it does detect the earnestness
of the notion in its onward march
dashing these figures to pieces and
comes to see how ill it fares with its
venerated gods who dare to trespass on
ground where the notion holds sway
then it is not itself the negative power
which actively interferes on the
contrary it clings to the selfless
thought of such power
clings to the consciousness of an alien
fate and produces the empty desire for
ease and comfort
and feeble talk of appeasement
in its fear of the higher powers which
are the immediate instruments of the
substance fearful of their struggles
amongst themselves and fearful of the
simple self of necessity which crushes
them as well as the living beings linked
with them in its compassion for these
living beings which it also knows to be
the same as itself it is conscious only
of a paralyzing terror of this movement
of equally helpless pity and as the end
of it all the empty repose of submission
to necessity
whose work is understood neither
as the necessary deed of the character
nor as the action of the absolute being
within itself
here in paragraph 734 hegel is now
explicitly bringing in a
key element or component of greek
tragedy one that often has
puzzled people
as nature points out in his as he says
all through hegelian work the birth of
tragedy out of the spirit of music
the chorus what is
the chorus doing and this is something
let me point out i as i teach
greek tragedies in my own classes to
young students generally
they're often befuddled by the existence
of the course what what are they doing
what's their function why couldn't they
just have somebody else do
the same thing as a single character
when they're looking say at sophocles
antigone or you know other
greek tragedies
and the answer is there's a function to
the chorus hegel thinks that the
function
is not one that's
explained in a single sentence as a
matter of fact you notice he's talking
about it in the next paragraph as well
it's going to be complex and the
chorus
exists as you could say part of the
ensemble
but it's also opposed to the
characters the chorus
is to some degree character-less
although sometimes they're named as such
right
in in the comedies of aristophanes
they'll often be particular things like
the frogs right
and in
you know the tragedies they're typically
townspeople the as we're going to talk
about in just a moment the the regular
people the ordinary people the people
who are not
standing out as
individuals and so what we have here
is the chorus
as part of what's on stage we have the
characters that we've just talked about
in the previous paragraph which are
going to be fleshed out a little bit
more in their function and activities
here and we have of course the audience
in the previous paragraph we saw that
hegel tells us that the audience is you
know as audience zooher they're the ones
who are listening right audience comes
from the audere to here
to listen to but they're also spectators
zoo shower right they're also
looking at what is is going on
um
and uh so
that's that's an important function
of the play you can't really have a
tragedy
as such in ancient times
without there being an audience and and
some people thought of the chorus as
basically
like
you could say
a bunch of people providing the audience
cues with how they're supposed to
interpret that and there's something
that hegel is saying towards the end
we're going to go into this quite a bit
having to do with emotions that if
you've read your aristotle or at least
had some references to aristotle you've
looked up wikipedia
entries about tragedy and you see that
well aristotle thought that tragedy was
about purifying catharsis the
audience of their emotions their pathe
of fear and pity in particular
hegel's talking about that here he's not
talking about that with respect to the
audience though he's talking about that
with respect to the
chorus
and so maybe hegel is doing a little bit
something a bit different than what
aristotle is sketching out here maybe we
should
set that to the side that set of
assumptions coming from aristotle about
the audience and about the mediating
function
of the
chorus
so that we can learn from hegel
so what does hagel actually say
the general ground already here
interesting translation right the
general ground on which the movement of
these
shapes these gestalten
produced from the notion takes place so
what are we talking about there
two things so general ground
could be universal ground algebra minor
boden right the the foundation the floor
the basis right and we're going to see
this boden come up again later on in the
paragraph
translated in a somewhat
different way
there we go
talking about trespassing on the ground
where the notion holds sway right now so
in both cases we have
the notion the begin the concept being
brought up here and we saw that in the
previous
paragraph actually we saw a transition
from a necessity which was
los
to a necessity which is the
power of the negative and the if in
which things take place there's an
articulation
that is happening a gathering together
and splitting apart and relating to each
other on the part of the characters you
might say the characters who matter as
it turns out the chorus matters too but
not in the way that individualities
matter the people who actually put on
the masks not of chorus members but of
creon or antigone or of
oedipus or of agamemnon or clydominestra
or pick whoever else you wish to to talk
about
so the general ground on which the
movement of these shapes produced from
the notion takes place these shapes
produced from the notion are the
characters
is the consciousness expressed in the
first imaginative language and here
miller reads in that of the epic where
the content devoid of itself is left
disunited does that make sense to read
it that way
i think so and he's saying that there's
something
connecting the
first imaginative language
language is important here right and
imagination uh foreshadowing is
important here too
um the play of fantasy we might say that
that of appearances
um
why is it important
that we don't have the kind of
complex unification going on
in the epic
at this point because that's reflected
in something similar
not exactly the same but something
similar
that's happening in this general ground
the
chorus right
and who does the chorus
represent
understanding here that
represent is kind of a loaded term right
because uh maybe we should say who does
the chorus depict who does the chorus
emerge from
so he says it's the commonality
as such
what's the commonality
so
gemini folk right it is the folk the
people the nation the tribe whatever you
want to translate that as
gemina the
average the
common the ordinary
the
plain person as opposed to the
distinctive person who would be a god or
a hero or at least
some character that is picked out
as such even if they're not particularly
heroic
they're given a name right there's no
name for the chorus except as a totality
the men of the village right or whoever
else is going to be the chorus
so
the commonality
as such
whose wisdom now that's interesting
whose wisdom
finds expression
utterance in the chorus of the elders
okay so it sounds like well that's cool
uh you know we've got the
people who matter the sort of elites and
then we've got the ordinary people they
have wisdom they have somebody or a set
of people representing them the chorus
of the elders you know the the ones who
can actually speak for stuff but notice
what hegel says immediately
following this
he says
in the powerlessness of this chorus the
commonality has its representative right
so this this chorus
they get to say things
they don't
have action
they don't even have
what we might call reported action
because remember in greek tragedy
they're not like you know somebody
stabbed somebody it's usually not
happening on stage they go off stage and
then somebody comes back and reports
they've killed themselves you know or
they they stabbed somebody else like
again great example of this i keep
returning to sophocles because it's the
play that i teach the most often when uh
jaiman tries to kill crayon
it's not being you know it's not like an
action movie where you know jaimon pulls
his sword and we have that
universal sword in the scabbard sound
that people use all the time that's
probably been turned into like a sound
wave file and then he goes after crayon
and crayon pulls his sword out and
parries and
that's not happening
it's the
import the essentiality of the action
that's being depicted and the chorus
doesn't do doesn't do anything right
what does hagel say the common people
themselves
constitute merely the positive and
passive material
of the individuality of the government
confronting it who's the government
it's going to be some of the characters
the the tyrant the
war leader the
in the case of like agamemnon and
clydominestra
before agamemnon shows up it's clyde
monastery she's been in charge of
agamemnon's regime
and now he's returning and she's like
laying plots and saying
listen i guess this will kill this guy
in the bathtub and oh look at he brought
back that war captain we're going to
take care of her as well you know
so the government
is the acting and
the chorus they have to listen they have
to suffer but they get to [ __ ] and moan
and admonish and bring stuff up they do
have a activity
in language
now notice what else he says here
we're going to come back to that point
in just a moment
lacking the power of the negative
it's unable to hold together
and subdue the riches and varied
abundance of the divine life the divine
life
is that of the
characters
could be gods could be heroes could be
demigods could be
you know the few ordinary people who get
to have names or at least titles guard
number one you know people like that
that is being held together
or rather
is emerging and connecting together as
the concept the notion that a particular
tragedy
is putting out there through the
mediation of the actors
and the thought that they are expressing
and the actions they're engaging in
right which has been arranged by no
longer the minstrel but the playwright
the tragedy in
the concept is at work in that the
concept is holding things together it is
not doing that in this
ground
bowden
of the chorus which really could be
called the general ground rather than
the universal ground because they think
that they're saying universal things but
they're not
so it's lacking the power of the
negative right it's unable to
bring all these things together but let
lets it all go its separate ways and now
notice what he says here really
interesting
because
tragedy epic forms of language spraka
right they are superior forms of
language discussed in this
section
of of the you know religion as a work of
art right
this
spiritual work of art what did we have
prior to this in the
um
abstract and the living work of art we
had other forms of language one of them
is the hymn
so what does the chorus do
extols
praises essentially each individual
moment
as an independent god
does that mean that they think that
every one of the characters is a god
no that's that's not the case and that's
not what hegel is saying they treat
each of them as if they are a god or we
might say in some cases as a
anti-god an evil
being that has to be
admonished or turned away but there are
forms of language that are hymns and the
chorus
is
praising through hymns these different
characters oh odysseus what are not just
oh oedipus what a wonderful guy you are
so powerful uh only you can solve the
riddle of what's going wrong with our
land right a
bad resolution to that one and we could
go on and on with examples so he says it
extols each individual moment as an
independent god first one then another
the chorus is unable to like stick to a
topic the chorus is unable to see
what is really happening the
interconnections the unfolding
of the concept
he goes on and he says where it does
detect the earnestness of the notion in
its onward march dashing
these figures to pieces
and comes to see how ill it fares with
its venerated gods who dare not trespass
on ground where the notion holds sway
there's that ground again bowdoin
then
it is not the negative power which
actively interferes
the chorus can only look on
it can't act
it can see oh i was we were not i was we
were full of crap when we were like
saying oh this is so wonderful so great
so awesome now we see all these things
coming together
and some of the characters being crushed
not everything can be resolved and this
produces
affects that we're going to talk about
in a moment
he goes on and he says
it's not the negative power which
actively interferes that is the
necessity
that we saw earlier on the contrary it
clings to the selfless thought of such
power
here's how the chorus represents things
to itself
in the play getting things partly right
and also partly wrong and there's also
interestingly we could say a reference
back
to one of the things that came up in the
reason section when we saw
reasoning consciousness
in its practical activity trying to
figure out what the
let's call it ethical project the you
know the ethical substances pursuing
pleasure
and winding up instead in necessity no
vendee kite right another word for this
is shikhsal faith we've talked about
this before
hegel has not used this word chic saul
uh in in describing greek uh epic and
tragedy up until this point but now he's
bringing it in but
fate can be understood as a
intensification
of the necessity that at first we
thought was concept less begrefloss now
we realize is a complexly articulated
concept in the tragedy
and which is going to crush some of the
characters
crushing others in the process too
so
what is this consciousness
on the part of the chorus it clings to
the
consciousness the voice sign of an alien
fate
shikhsal alien there is fender right so
it could be hostile as well
alien fate consciousness of a fate that
doesn't really make sense this is more
again like the lara
you know not vendi kait the the empty uh
necessity that was taking place we're
going to see emptiness is going to be
mentioned here as well so the
consciousness of an alien fate
and it produces
the empty desire
right
empty desire for ease and comfort the
holy god right resting having what you
need
the chorus is not able to see
the true
[Music]
value the true
nobility the true
tragic nature of the actions and the
sufferings
and the conflicts
and the justifications of the characters
involved so they tell them things like
why don't you take it easy why are you
getting so worked up about this
let's all calm down you know we don't
want to like tempt the gods and uh
bring about all sorts of problems do we
right they they want things to be
nice and easy
as if they ever were i mean it's it's
this is a total side note but it's funny
to see the chorus in these tragedies
about you know conflicts that have been
going on and on and on for years and
years being like
can't we all just get along
you know
when and you can say when the hell did
we ever all get along when was this this
wonderful time that you're going back to
when things were normal right so
consciousness of alien fate
empty desire now you know
we could talk about this in terms of
kenos and kenosis empty in the sense of
being valueless
uh being grounded on nothing you know
and then we have feeble talk rada notice
he doesn't say raka it's not language
it's just chattering feeble talk of
appeasement can't again can't we all
just get along it would be so nice if we
didn't have to be so dramatic about all
this stuff and the characters are like
no no we're dramatic characters so
this is the mistaken perspective
of the chorus but that plays
an important role
in the tragedy the the chorus is the
ground the bowden right that you need
in order to
have this drama playing itself out if
you say uh we don't want any rum dums we
don't want any ordinary people
contaminating the wonderful field of our
tragedy and you like push the chorus off
the stage you know get the hell out of
here
you don't really have the drama in its
original sense anymore and maybe you're
losing a vital connection
with the in-person audience of greek
tragedy
maybe you need the chorus there right
even though they're misunderstanding
things trying to you know reduce things
to a tawdry level and now here is where
we get to the discussion of the affects
miller's translation is a little bit
periphrastic uh and plagnastic that
means that he's adding in some some
terms hegel doesn't say you know fearful
fearful feel fearful over and over again
he just says in it he talks about fear
fercht right it's fear of the higher
powers which are the immediate
instruments of the substance who's whose
fear the chorus the chorus is afraid of
them um
fearful
it just goes on in the german and says
of their struggles it doesn't say
fearful of their struggles because we've
already got fear so fear of
x y and z
so
why in this case is the struggles among
the
characters
and fearful as well of the simple self
of necessity which crushes them as well
as the living beings linked with them
okay so we've got a lot of fear going on
here right and we've got things that are
fear provoking the chorus exists within
the narrative right and the chorus isn't
like the spectators who can it could be
watching and be like wow that sucks
what's happening with agamemnon i hope
he doesn't get in that bathtub sort of
like when people go to horror movies and
they're sitting in the audience
and okay this is this really irritates
the hell out of some people but i think
it's really funny myself and you know
the the person is um instead of like
going back to their car and driving away
from the camp they're like
there's a light on over there
in that cabin i should go investigate
that and then you know they're getting
to the door and somebody in the audience
shouts out don't go in there
we can imagine something like that may
be happening with spectators
they're not directly
in the drama the chorus
if things go wrong with the main
characters these are the ordinary people
things are going to be screwed up for
them too so they are fearful they're
they're worried about what's going to
happen when these gods collide these
heroes fight against each other
and and make stupid decisions
right
so fear is part of it
notice what else he talks about later
paralyzing terror
schreichen so we've got this entire
modality
of fear
going on an emotional affective
modality very important going from the
let's say medium level to the highest
level terror paralyzing terror
that that occurs
what else do we have going on
a different modality
as well
he says
in its compassion for these living
beings
which it also knows to be the same
as itself
we can
look at
the
characters and say holy crap
wow i'm glad that my
uh
my
dad isn't also my brother
what a screwed up family that is the
sons and daughters of oedipus
you know
we can feel mitt leiden is the the
german here compassion
um we also have this other term coming
up
down pity right that miller is
translating and so we have two really
important modalities of emotion
these are the ones that aristotle brings
up in
uh
book one of the poetics right where
we're talking about tragedy these are
the things that aristotle says the
audience is being pure purified of these
are the things that the chorus
is expressing
and feeling and perhaps that's how the
catharsis takes place we don't actually
know that much about that there's lots
of theorizing but um
at this point we're not we're not
getting that so we've got um equally
helpless pity and then at the end of it
he says
the empty repose of submission to
necessity
now notice again still the perspective
of the chorus whose work
is understood neither as the necessary
deed
of the character that's hot once again
we have this top handle distinction
going on the necessary d to the
character the characters are expressions
to some degree of bits and pieces of
necessity
right of the concept
nor is the action of the absolute being
within itself the handle of the absolute
being the
overall necessity the chorus doesn't get
this
but the chorus is just part of the
picture
and so we're learning more about
what hegel takes to be essential to
greek tragedy by looking at all of this
the chorus has
an important role but a
one-sided and
mistaken conception of what's really
taking place
and the audience is seeing
all of this at least if they are
listening and watching and not just like
you know chomping on on foodstuffs and
drunk or something like that chatting
with each other they're actually there
to watch the drama
they get to see this entire thing play
out and it's one more time i do want to
emphasize the chorus for hegel is this
general ground that you need sort of
like a background
for having the things in the foreground
that we want to focus upon
you